Bueno hasta el momento no hay
interrupciones en el transporte por
ejemplo algo que sucede con frecuencia
eso podría deberse a que esta
movilización es menos seguida que la del
martes pasado entre otras razones porque
estamos en las vacaciones escolares no
obstante se espera manifestaciones en al
menos 80 ciudades del país algunas se
organizan frente a prefecturas o
empresas donde continúan las huelgas por
mejores salarios según la convocatoria
el objetivo es obligar esas empresas a
iniciar negociaciones salariales y al
gobierno a subir al sueldo mínimo
aumentar los ingresos en la misma medida
que la inflación que supera ya el 5% Y
probablemente otro impulso a la
movilización sea la propuesta intacta
del presidente macrón de retrasar la
edad de jubilación de al menos 64 años
cuatro más de lo que propone la cgt la
secretaría general de ese sindicatos
reprochó al mandatario que no abre
ninguna puerta de las negociaciones al
respecto y que no queda otra salida que
la acción de los trabajadores